un débat qui revient qui est assez chaud
bouillant je ne vous le cache pas et qui
revient très régulièrement dans
l'actualité saisie de l'abolition de la
corrida
si certains revendiquent une tradition
les défenseurs des animaux dénoncent
quant à eux la cruauté de cette pratique
c'est un sujet de seignosse le code
pénal réprime tous les actes de cruauté
contre les animaux mais la corrida fait
exception la spa
comme d'autres associations demandent
aux députés et sénateurs l'interdiction
pure et simple de la tauromachie
comment pouvons-nous nous regarder en
laissant des pervers dans des arènes
regarder des actes aussi horribles mais
pour les passionnés il n'est pas
possible de comparer un chien ou un chat
à l'animal qui entre dans l'arène je
vous invite à visiter les élevages de
taureaux c'est là qu'il est le mieux
respecté lui offrant ensuite de mourir
en combattant
si sa nature la spa diffuse une vidéo
pour sensibiliser les pouvoirs publics
la pétition lancée sur internet en
faveur de l'abolition de la corrida
recueille déjà plus de quarante et un
mille signatures on est même monté pour
l'instant à 47 mille signatures ya 70
corridas par an en france en espagne à
une baisse de fréquentation de 16%
malgré tout ça reste le deuxième
spectacle de masse après le football en
espagne et en france 75% des français
seraient pour son interdiction
même si pourtant lorsqu elles sont
organisées il ya évidemment c'est s'est
plaint les arènes son plein et ça
fonctionne très bien qu'est ce que vous
en pensez je vais commencer par vous
d'amiens alors valérie oui vous savez à
quel point les avis sont habituellement
trancher sur ce plateau et là je dois
vous avouer que j'ai lardière 30 entre
deux tabourets parce que je ne sais pas
vraiment le cul entre deux chaises côte
feuillée simple exactement parce que
alors ces images sont insoutenables je
vais pas vous mentir c'est à dire que
les coups de piques sur le taureau les
mises à mort le sang qui dégouline tout
ça ça génère des images insoutenables et
forcément personne ne peut être pour ça
en même temps en revanche la tauromachie
fait partie de notre richesse nationale
au même titre que la danse vous apprécié
la richesse nationale ça fait partie du
patrimoine d'ailleurs ça a été un temps
à accepter au patrimoine immatériel de
l'humanité et du coup ça fait partie du
patrimoine et il faut savoir aussi que
le taureau avant d'entrer dans l'arène
un traitement de faveur paradoxalement
qui est assez favorable c'est-à-dire et
liez pardonnez moi je comprends pas il
est très bien traitée le taureau de
combat l'on sent déçu par la façon
d'être élevé c'est ça
rumba dans le taureau de combat est très
bien élevé dans la mesure où il dispose
de plusieurs hectares et je trouve
finalement avec le recul que leur destin
n'est pas si cruel si l'on comparé leur
destin par rapport à celui des vaches
laitières par exemple qui sont en
batterie et qui sont emmenés dans des
abattoirs dont on connaît aujourd'hui
les dérives les divines vous savez je
suis très attaché mois aux traditions
non il y en a chez moi je suis
originaire de la martinique est chez moi
c'est vrai qu'il ya des combats de coqs
comme en thaïlande qui sont organisées
dans des pit et tous ont fait les les
animaux se battre donc je peux
comprendre le le côté culturel et
l'attachement qu'on peut avoir envers
toutes ces traditions
je vois arriver un néanmoins la mennais
en mai oui parce que c'est insoutenable
ça vous fendre le coeur en deux cantons
quand on comprend moi je l' ai compris a
14 ans quand francis cabrel avait avait
fait la corrida sa fameuse chanson c'est
vraiment cette chanson qui m'a
sensibilisé à cette cause et avons
ressenti que pourrait avoir le taureau
je me suis renseigné un peu et j'ai vu
que line bultot qui était pratiqué et au
delà d'ailleurs de alors il faut
expliquer les malades dos et c'est la
même façon enfin c'est une solide hors
machines il n'y a pas de mise à mort du
taureau exactement le tomoe le taureau
est gracié et pourquoi on ne pourrait
pas adopter cette réforme pour tous les
aficionados de la corrida
d'accord on ne va pas oui moi je trouve
ça incroyable on assiste en fait dans ce
spectacle à la mise à mort d'un animal
avec une mise en scène incroyable mais
c'est la mise à mort d'un animal le
monsieur dit oui mais on le traite bien
avant ce mois que je t'ai dit damien on
traite bien avant le condamné à mort ben
oui on donne en général une dernière
clope mais là il fume pas la wii nommé
donc mais mais quand même c'est la mise
à mort d'un animal téléphonie à dire par
exemple que si tu vois un chien se faire
battre dans la rue c'est une honte
euh si quelqu'un jette son animal avec
mais là ça te dérange pas et ils ont des
arguments très spéciaux l'argument des
arguments des patrimoines la tradition
celle des x 10 6 avant dans l'antiquité
on abate les animaux les saignées etc
ah ouais alors sa mutuelle faut
continuer à jean-michel je suis pas
d'accord sur toute la ligne avec toi en
fait parce que dans ce cas là on va
considérer qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures pourquoi mange-t-on de la viande
pourquoi mange-t-on de la viande issue
d'un abattoir où il ya eu des dérives on
sait particulièrement qu'il a eue de la
souffrance animale derrière et pourquoi
on tolère ça alors dans ce cas là enfin
tu vois il ya deux poids deux mesures et
ce jugement cas du tout on est en train
de mettre des caméras dans les abattoirs
pour vérifier que les animaux soient
battues correctement pour éviter qu'ils
s'ouvrent pour le faire avec
décharge électrique et état hélas non et
que je te piquer que je te fais c'est
nier que je t'ai stocks mais si je te
rates je recommence et cetera qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais oui oui
effectivement tu nous parles de
tradition je rappelle juste que par
exemple au moyen âge une des traditions
quand les femmes paraîtront l'homme
étaient des pics dans la bouche
on a arrêté forte heureusement pour moi
parce que je parle beaucoup avec le code
pénal réprime les actes de cruauté
envers les animaux
je n'ai toujours pas pour compris
pourquoi il avait cet extrait exception
pour la corrida effectivement peut-être
qu'ils vivent bien avant mais après il
se retrouve à vivre des choses qui
doivent être d'une violence et d'une
souffrance quand le monsieur notamment
dans le reportage qui était un éleveur à
qui participait à cela dit oui mais en
fait c'est sa nature au taureau de
combattre donc finalement il finit en
beauté
c'est l'argument du monsieur sait pas
lire mais voilà qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ces aficionados qui disent
finalement c'est très bien combattre
sans famille à mort et sans être
violenté et sans être seigner devant des
gens et d'ailleurs on se rend compte
notamment à nîmes qu'à une baisse de
fréquentation des corridas et les gens
qui vont à nîmes notamment pour les
férias il que 6 % qui auront les trouvez
pas ça ne les intéresse plus parce que
des gens ou je pense commencent à
prendre conscience qu effectivement ce
genre de spectacle c'est peut-être pas
bon non plus pour tout le monde alors je
sais qu'on va se prendre beaucoup de pro
corrida parce qu'ils sont plus hargneux
kehl et vegan mais moi je suis désolé on
devrait l'interdire c'est pas pour rien
que ça a été mis au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco sur le sait quelques années
plus tard ce qu'on s'est dit banon on
peut pas laisser faire ça pas
aujourd'hui alors qu'on pourrait bien
très rapidement le chlore en fait parce
que ce que je voulais dire surtout c'est
que en fait avant il est très bien
traitée et c'est ça en fait qu'il faut
souligner c'est qu'un véritable récente
du toréador pour le taureau parce que
c'est élevé au rang d'animal sacré et
malheureusement ce respect là le
bien-être animal etc
on le retrouve pas forcément avant les
abattoirs voilà qui ces animaux qui sont
élevées en batterie on a posé la
question à nos téléspectateurs la
corrida ce que vous êtes pour ou est-ce
que vous êtes contre et vous êtes contre
à 86% c'est une immense majorité est
pour part donc combien 14 14% pour en
tout cas il ya un chat à qui on a parlé
de corrida visiblement la réaction c'est
ouais c'est pas c'est pas ça quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vivien d'achat il n'est qu'à regarder du
closing il nous a collé une mon fils ne
ferait pas ça allait bien l'élever en
clair missionary les très bien l'anglais